what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation
we are back joined by Sally lemonade all
the way in the heart of the Empire State
Building how are you Sally I am great
that's great I love how you saying so I
have to sing oh yeah yeah yeah no no
it's a great time we gotta have a back
and forth you know how this goes report
what are we finally concluding today we
are finally concluding with the Pitch
Perfect Trilogy which I might add so far
has been Pitch Perfect so let's not ruin
it let's temper our expectations I've
heard a lot of people say it's the least
strong one first one still my favorite
out of the two we've watched so far low
expectations which means we might be
pleasantly surprised that's that's all
we need right now is to be pleasantly
surprised and what would pleasantly
surprise us is if you leave a like on
this video please go ahead and do that
also go check out Sally laminamanakos
Channel she is really pushing to get her
Spider-Man short film done spend a
hundred thousand dollars half of that
payment for it comes from these Pitch
Perfect videos
so much money she is on track right now
but guys go support her on YouTube and
as always if you want to catch our
full-length reaction where you can sync
up with your own copy of Pitch Perfect
that is available for a super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page covers
so many things exclusively over there
and thank you to all have been joining
we've been a lot of pledges so far
because we've been covering so much
Sally are you ready to get your hormone
Harmon I tried doing something there do
you see it your harm off like
harmonizing yeah I try I see it wasn't
working
[Music]
is is this an action going International
Greg
007 coming to join
[Music]
what is going on right now
it's getting late
oh my God yes
I just want to sing along but it'll be
off sync
[Music]
oh Aubrey's just back with them okay
okay
[Music]
I love this song so much this was a
strong opening song
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
were they being held captive is this
like a movie that they're in or
something there's no way
[Music]
what is happening they must have been
being held captive
hey they got our attention man
titties is your sound equipment you're
in the danger zone we have security and
I carry mace
cling to you like mom jeans to a camel
toe jeez
[Music]
is that wait Eminem
this is my song and I feel like
y'all should play my mix
this is embarrassing man it's my job to
make you the best little pimple that you
can be a little pimple little pimple he
didn't make a pop hit
all right
nicely done so thank you what I mean is
what you gave me was a steaming pile of
pimp well Becca
it's on her period wow oh my God Shark
Week it's nasty it's our job bruh we're
producers we bring his vision to life
I finally quit my job and I'm free
free I'm never going back to that job
again it's the best day of my life I
mean I can't be a music producer without
Integrity she's no longer with her
boyfriend
clearly because she finally got her
dream job but then quit you go back
together with Jesse no you know the long
distance thing didn't work he lives 20
000 miles away with his girlfriend and
their cat ah Jesse I quit my job he got
fired oh come on
I quit you're kind of making it worse
but let this negative energy be released
seriously open your legs they'll come
out no no
she's so gross yeah you need to pay the
rent
yeah you could get a job you know you're
in shock you need something to eat
[Music]
hey Chloe why aren't you guys ready
they all live together what did you wear
that to work yeah underneath my scrubs
Oh I thought I'd never see that outfit
again God tonight is you know Bella's
reunion
at the Brooklyn aquarium hello that's
tonight yes oh you know what I will take
it what happened she got fired today
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna say that now every time I see
you thank you so much for inviting us of
course so what do you want us to sing
tonight a little who run the world it's
bulletproof you didn't tell us what the
crowd was but I um
call backs we invited you to watch us
sing ooh that hurts that was a major
miscommunication
I just thought you guys were so busy
with your your awesome jobs an amazing
life
[Music]
oh my God their lives aren't amazing no
no they're like having to work real jobs
Fat Amy Winehouse
you know you've got these great jobs
right I have one of those yeah
what a bunch of lying pitches
could dress up to get up but guess what
I'm never gonna be that girl who's
living in a Barbie world
God I love these musical numbers really
does something for me nipple chubs
really this works every time
[Music]
you're all old now
you're so bright and shiny they look
like they was all breastfed
[Music]
[Applause]
God I love Haley Steinfeld she's so good
[Music]
what a cool backdrop to perform to yeah
those fish are probably like what is
happening yeah a toast to the most
amazing group of women I have ever known
I would do anything to sing with you
guys again
okay okay
I've mentioned that my dad is in the
Army and like basically killed Osama Bin
Laden right and every year the Uso puts
on this performance to entertain and
support the troops and this year DJ
Khaled is hosting no cool what if I
could get us an invite
to sing No to run military dark Ops
yes of course
you're disappointed yeah sing together
again and maybe I'll see my dad or maybe
I won't you know because he has
something really important to do or
maybe I'll be the most important thing
in his life this time
oh God can you fly when you're eight
months pregnant what no
um
no way do you guys even notice
no we saw you in a shot the actress is
gonna get cut from the rest of the movie
who wrote that wow do you know who the
father is
character continues
so I guess Emily you're in was I not
always in
um
man these two need to find a life
knocking them this documentary is
happening we're making a beautiful
documentary in fact we got to set up
where are we going to set up John
straight ahead
okay oh I like this movie oh cue the
pony song two important things to know
before we begin
uh first up is a sound check if they
have you back to the hotel by 1430 back
here for the Big Show at 1700. 1700 is
that like later than the night it's five
okay whatever
so on the tour we've got three bands
over here we got saddle up this is Young
sparrow and DJ Dragon nuts and behind me
is ever moist
oh
ever moist ever moist my man social
anxiety when he's not behind the
turntable it's kind of crazy so be easy
huh
hello
[Music]
I could be obesity
is that Ruby Rose you're wondering yeah
it has nothing to do with the nationally
televised salute to the Troops special
where DJ Khaled is going to pick one
group to open for him at the end of this
tour that was a lot of exposition nicely
done
just to call it out you guys are seeing
other people's songs right like the
cover band uh actually Emily writes
original songs for the Bellas I mean I
don't really do it anymore
hey shut up get with the program and it
was one of your dads who gave you this
spot on the tour right they just don't
like showing the spotlight so they're
trying to intimidate us a riff off
always there has to be one okay
I feel like this is going to be really
embarrassing
[Music]
I'm coming up
so you dare look back just keep your
eyes on me
[Music]
dance with me
DJ Cal it's not even watching
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
my Bella Sam
[Music]
they could just swing into this can't
they hell yeah we just took the last
word of the old song and matched it with
the first word the new song but you stay
on Tempo stay on beat stay on pitch and
of course keep it in the relative key
that was great that was really well done
okay okay so condescending artist s know
we're Jewish what
oh they are acapelling
[Music]
oh they know their Jews
and she has a cross on her ears
[Music]
what I'll go
logo
okay
cool
night call me
[Laughter]
I mean they're they're banding together
[Music]
oh oh Chicago likes what he sees he's so
cute
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
what
even just for a day
okay you guys aren't even in it Beyonce
could be Jewish wait Ariana Grande's
Jewish this is Beyonce no the other one
Loved Me Harder was Ariana Grande
zombie apocalypse
[Music]
a child is lonely taken
of course this is what you come up with
whether you think of the zombie
apocalypse I wouldn't have come up with
this song
[Music]
it's pretty cool cover not gonna lie
yeah
[Music]
let's go
they have some serious competition
[Music]
[Applause]
is this a zombie apocalypse I mean I
guess someone would be throwing a
grenade a zombie maybe the category is
just a kickoff point
s
the taking off of the sunglasses
[Music]
yeah this is pretty awesome yeah this is
awesome we want fellas are doing what
they do best quitting
[Music]
John Lithgow that's the fuzzy hair man
we saw in the beginning Emily is it true
what you said back there are you really
not writing anymore not right now anyway
I've got 21 credits that I'm taking this
semester the GRE is coming up right
around the corner who cares right I'm
actually from Georgia why are you here
long story short I was in the NG but my
CEO recommended me for OCS after AIT I
came OPC
Swoon meet every guy that shows me
attention dogs
I love dogs animals are cute you're cute
I mean what what about you me just just
let that compliment slide
I like I love love I love being
committed to love not to you but to like
I love
um like orange oh my God such an off put
so off-putting look she's just nervous
Greg it's desperate Sally
then I'm desperate because I do that so
what's the plan I really think we should
just drink stay true to ourselves and it
will all figure itself out we have a
very stupid person
foreign
[Music]
I mean in the beginning I was like it's
someone's dad but then it wasn't but now
it is so
[Music]
what someone's gonna be messing with
them wrote a spade here we go girl don't
give me away
[Music]
so they do covers too
does everyone just do covers oh most
rappers sample and do covers anyway
but I'm wondering if this was made for
the movie or if it's already a song I
saw you do the sound check um yeah the
rip-off thing yeah I don't know why we
keep challenging people to those we we
don't ever actually win oh
no I I work with music Executives and
they they don't look like you ow
they suck
I'm a music producer I'm sort of
freelancing right now and I sing for fun
people leave it open for DJ Khaled in
the end just tell him that you sing for
fun I'm gonna go now I'll see you later
but I'll be watching good luck that was
painful to watch I bet he's sleazy
I bet he is part of the mob I bet he's
part of a criminal organization yes I
think so too Greg calling it
all these women are fawning over so many
guys
[Applause]
[Music]
ever moist who came up with that name
does anyone have an Ever moist tell it
my grandma's in a band right now never
moist
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you compete with actual
instruments you have to use your voice
as an instrument Gregory but yeah that's
that's gonna be hard yeah okay so
they're pretty and Polished and sexy and
like I don't know I was just listing
stuff and I'm sad God damn you DJ Khaled
stop nodding DJ khaled's nodding oh no
not the Khalid nod
[Applause]
away I shouldn't be clapping we are ever
most what a seductive name but I kind of
hate the word moist everyone hates the
word noise yeah I don't know anyone
that's like Yay moist is my favorite
word in acapella group with a few
YouTube clicks
cheers what's wrong with this crowd you
guys have no idea how great they are
Hello Kitty girl girl
oh that sounds great catchy song Come On
[Music]
hell yeah
come on crowd you know this shit's
awesome
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's awesome that's awesome
[Music]
he keeps eyeing just her yep
I can't tell if he's evil or not though
I feel like he just wants her but not
the Bellas yeah
[Music]
wow that's that my friend was Taps from
the back of the house it's to honor
Fallen Soldiers
look at this they look like idiots this
is the best thing for the movie
[Laughter]
if we had bass then we wouldn't need me
and we're still not clear why Jessica
and Ashley are even here did they just
say our names don't be stupid
[Laughter]
you just suck balls in front of DJ
Khaled okay I say we all get up we get
dressed we go over there and we show him
that we are not a joke so like seduce
him like what are you talking about
I bet it all I'm 21. this is just like
James Bond
Casino Royale
oh there's the bag and that was sunshine
[Applause]
oh it's our father still a bad guy so
weird
I don't know what's happening
why are we hiding I don't know oh my
gosh they're bringing back their gay
moment what is this about what are you
guys doing
nothing this should have just made it
happen
maybe that's a Twist at the end Greg
what are the time you smuggle drugs into
bounce a lot and I had to see him get
this is not beside the story I was
expecting in this movie
yeah
did you even find me I'm where you've
been for years your crotch was shown all
over a news station so it's not really a
tell us some time away
that would just make me run faster
[Laughter]
they just let this crazy guy start
singing yeah
and they are playing the instruments
to him you want to give it a go no no
possibly this
it has a little Loop going
work your magic
they missed the part where his chest
inside an NCAA they could just steal
this from her or she could steal it from
DJ Khaled
[Music]
this sounds just like DJ Khaled
I go to uh Khalid oh okay
[Music]
isn't she amazing American woman they're
the best ones buy them
an Englishman or
otter in general oh my God so you were
just with aubry's Dad I'm so excited to
see your show it's just too bad that it
can't make it son of a expect
finite disappointment and remember
there's always more
yes
release the bees
[Applause]
Brothers
[Music]
there's some soundproof headphones
how do you know it's the bells how did
you know it was the Bellas everything's
the pillows the baby
wow look at the mice what's her name
Baby Fat Amy or Baby Fat Patricia you
can choose her name's gonna be Bella I
named her Bella oh you called it Sally
let's go
Bella is on my shirt
ciao Bellas who wants to go to Italy oh
me four countries in four days and then
DJ Khaled will announce the winner When
we arrive in France
[Applause]
[Music]
yo these outfits are on points they
really are whole movie
[Music]
everyone looks pretty hot in those
outfits yeah but specifically Anna
Kendrick that's why the British guy
wants her
[Music]
yeah
cool way to honor the troops
[Music]
it really sounds like there's an
instrument she went hard with that one
um
[Music]
I wonder if they'll sing like God Bless
the USA or something it must be kind of
lonely always being away from your
family but in the Army is kind of like
having a second family yeah of course
you know when it's over you go your
separate ways but you're always going to
be there for each other right they're
like the army
what do you mean at no I just don't
recognize the actor but he's really cute
well DJ Khaled wants to meet you how
beautiful oh thank you so nice need a
drink Rebecca ASAP have a seat make
yourself a home I'm just waiting for him
to say DJ Khaled I want you to open up
for me tomorrow night Becca DJ Khaled
yes there it is
that is great you are not going to
regret this I the fellas are gonna die
can I go tell them I I think you
misunderstood it's just you babe he
doesn't want the ballots we won you take
the opportunity I can tell that you was
just playing around I see I seen
something I heard something then I felt
something a heart attack
[Music]
but I'm part of a group and we all have
something special there's usually one
who goes off on their own you're the
hairy styles you've really gone as far
as you can with the girls it's time for
you to now flourish on your own
independent like Beyonce like Justin
Timberlake come with me a second bless
up
[Laughter]
bless up
we're talking about my family I'm I'm
not interested tough decision I get no
it's not what do you mean the last movie
you wanted to ditch him to have time to
change she's grown geez Sally pay
attention
I really am sorry
he's still playing the piano
what if I we leave tonight tomorrow is
like the big televised event with DJ
Khaled and they're definitely going to
pick the Bellas to perform so oh no he's
on the hunt he has to get out a
Caribbean tour you ever been to
Martinique the Cayman Islands yep he's
fleeing
she's figuring it out hello know exactly
what's in the Cayman Island that bank
account the mum set up for me on my 13th
birthday she said it was just a bit of
an allowance but I know she didn't want
me to ever need your dirty money what is
this movie
180 million oh my God am I gonna learn
to open my
mind get the money this man bothering
you yes he is yeah sir step away from
the Bella could he get any harder
goodbye circus
I feel like we've just been shouting at
this movie this whole time I know I'm
sorry I was trying to add to I have to
feel like I'm doing the same thing
what I feel like I've been doing the
same thing
[Music]
we're liven it up a little
we got ghost sent me to take you to the
Uso reception Chicago never mentioned
this man is full of yeah he's gonna
kidnap them we need to find our friends
Becca and fat Amy right oh they are
already there let's not keep this
handsome French man waiting these women
are so weak for the men men make us dumb
Greg you should see what woman do to men
what do we do we never mind
[Music]
there's always room for another musical
number
right maybe
kind of scared yeah I would be wrapping
myself right now
I'm floating they're on a boat
I would be so afraid yeah that they're
just gonna like drown us
use your heels break the window
foreign
swim with the fishies hey Amy um I need
to talk to you about something that's
kind of important I had just a sec I'm
on a call okay
[Laughter]
what are we doing why are we not calling
the police or Chicago is my time and if
my dad's season he'll take off this is
serious Bellows could really get hurt
not on my watch Amy come on she's
surprisingly calm about this
Anna Kendrick yeah
10 minutes ladies guys you know what we
should do where did you come from I've
been here the whole time I'm just small
me
if we only have 10 minutes left then
sing one more song baby can't see
[Music]
this is so weird
I am admittedly very amused by what's
happening okay
you act like she's human
this just turned into John by four
this is exactly John Wick for
what is happening I'm just glad they're
really committed to this yeah yeah I
expect nothing less
[Music]
Patricia okay all my former jelly
wrestling coach slash babysitter
what is this so much
[Laughter]
[Music]
nunchucks skills let's go this isn't
doing too bad actually
[Music]
whoa oh my gosh
yes this is like The Fat Amy movie to be
honest
oh my God I don't know how this movie
came to be this way
you're living for it I'm sober I'm so
here for it right now
[Applause]
[Music]
meanwhile Hey DJ Khaled just wants me to
join
God we're alive
um DJ Khaled and his team they didn't
pick the Bell as they picked Becca but I
said no because I feel exactly how you
feel you guys are family and you don't
walk away from family okay you can't say
no you've got to do it oh they're gonna
be like listen we almost died follow
your dreams I kind of feel like I've
been saying something did that affect
the entire oh my God Emily
[Laughter]
a music career would interfere with my
business so tiny Jewish truck you work
at the jew struck I own and just secured
Capital to franchise congratulations
cool beans what what
finally left my body
what I'm Esther
any questions
I think it's time that we go in with the
next chapter of Our Lives you
this is so funny
oh you like it their words Greg you just
get out there and you crush it
she loves her don't forget
[Music]
oh how wholesome oh they were so
supportive I don't know if I I feel like
I'd be a tad jealous well they don't
have a YouTube channel Greg they should
be jealous of you
are they gonna do the DJ Khaled song
is there like a famous song from this
uh I don't know I introduce you to Becca
Mitchell you only get one shot one
opportunity
[Music]
it's gonna end with a solo performance
that's interesting well the first movie
was like centered around her so it's
kind of cool full circle heaven knows I
was just a young boy didn't know what I
wanted to be I was every little hungry
school girl's pride and joy and I guess
it was enough for me God and I love her
voice
I think there's something you should
know
does DJ Khaled know about this I don't
know record jail canceled
[Music]
[Applause]
can they hear her they don't have mics
probably not
oh
[Music]
they have instruments now you can't hear
the acapella group over the instruments
oh John Wick was playing guitar did you
see it
[Music]
this is so sweet
I'm Gonna Miss This trilogy
[Music]
foreign
that made me cry a little bit
it hits harder knowing it's the last
movie
[Music]
[Applause]
that's really sweet
those look like real tears I wonder if
that was like the last day of filming or
something that'd be great you got all
that on camera right John sure I did all
right because the red light was not on
so I just had to ask
everyone's nightmare that shoots things
guys it's like my dad always says always
give a hundred percent unless you're
donating blood he's gonna be there
the cheese is real
wow you smell like Skittles kind of
Taste the rainbow you can definitely
taste them
oh
living a dream
oh oh that's nice
it's just us
it's always been just us
this is so uncomfortable Gail
I love you
I wonder if he ad-libbed that just for
that reaction that's funny
[Music]
oh memories memories
what the can she really do that
okay I don't know
[Music]
the mermaid
uh what what was that what where's that
friendship
I feel like they just probably shot a
lot more and then they just didn't use
it
[Music]
cup
is it so transcending nice
[Laughter]
okay
all over that to me too
even though it's not too many shallow me
I know yeah I didn't actually hear you
say that and then as I was watching the
scene go and I was like this guy looks
like Timothy Charlemagne yeah I wonder
if Sally was trying to say he looked
like Timothy that is
really in my head the whole time
um yeah you know people really
downplayed this one and can I pause it
why because
and can you hear it
yes you can still hear it I've lowered
it no I know
right now that's hilarious we'll suck it
up okay I'll just I'll turn it down
[Laughter]
uh yeah people were um saying how it was
you know like the weakest of the three
and I don't know I kind of loved it or
something
I don't know how to describe it like
it's I don't know if it was necessarily
the weakest but it was definitely the
most different out of the three so maybe
maybe people just didn't like it because
I expected something else and they took
a lot like a few of the characters out
of it like Ben Platt wasn't in it
the original Jesse wasn't I keep
forgetting the actor's name there were
just different characters so
it was strange because when they got to
the scene on the when they get kidnapped
and they're on the boat
for some reason because that that
surprisingly was working so well for me
because of how committed they were like
you love action movies so this is
probably
because it was like a parody action
yeah I mean beyond that it was it was
such a left-field choice even though
they try to setting you up like I get
why they do the beginning because it
would just feel like maybe too jarring
if they didn't yeah at the beginning
um but the the fact that that actually
worked for just how because they were so
committed to it that it was so strange
and then first it started making the
rest of the movie that came prior to it
really it all started clicking for me
like how weird this one is yeah and then
by the time and like they get to the end
when they're all like that I thought the
comedy was just working so well when
they're all gathered and you find out
they all find out that you know that
last scene was very strong between all
of them yeah
you know they're all at the table and
they're like yeah of course we want you
to have this career just how supportive
loving they are they're like oh the
devil's left my body my name is Esther
that was amazing
it just made suddenly there's a whole
movie just clicked for me in that moment
and it started to really work because
yeah the leading prior to it
it was it was a little it was like I was
really I was enjoying it
um but then the strangeness of this
whole film started to really sing no pun
intended uh and then by the end I
thought it was really
just that active uh willingness share
the spotlight and love uh really was
very
very touching something I would never do
in a million years that part
yeah because you're like my ego's too
big like I couldn't do that
um it's about me it's about me let me
just talk Sally
just listen to me I'm just gonna remove
you from the video
when people don't let me know no please
Greg
now let's say
these are they're very noise canceling
I'm gonna stop yelling and take these
off of it what I was gonna say was this
movie probably home for a lot of people
maybe it did a little bit for me but the
writer strike stuff going on because
it's like all these girls had this dream
of being big singers and then as I got
older and started like real jobs then
they realized it had different passions
now and wanted to pursue you know more I
guess realistic
uh passions and features so that part
was really
um hitting home for me a little bit but
I almost wish I really really wish that
they would have hid the fact that this
guy was her dad and was related to
Fatima until the very end like that
would have been a mic drop thing for me
but like you knowing the whole time that
this was
how it was gonna happen like they didn't
really leave that mystery for the ending
once he realized he uh he's a bad guy
and that he's her father
but other than yeah you know what I mean
I wish they they didn't yet tease him at
the beginning and and I wish they they
cut it once she burst through the window
and started spraying the fire hydrant uh
the fire hydrant uh the oh my God what
the hell is this called
um at first I was like wait it is a fire
just like I don't know why I thought
fire extinguisher yeah yeah yeah Jesus
we both were like yeah
she brought a fire hydrant
um yeah she started spraying the I think
then you that's when you could have
ended it right there because you already
have seen I think you gave away too much
yeah with the explosion I agree get away
yeah I thought they gave it away a
little too much
um
but yeah you actually bring up an
interesting point that
yeah that's a really interesting point
because normally it's Hollywood and
these movies will end especially after
like three movies of acapella career of
yeah they all become like a successful
band or singers or whatever you know
they that's normally the direction it
would go so there is something relatable
and poignant about most of them
and like ending on a note of no I'm
gonna go to this career path and I'm
okay with that I'm happy with that and
this is a part of my past and it's
something on the lowest treasure instead
of being like I have to it has to be
this or I'm a failure in life you know
yeah I think that was actually a really
a really meaningful thing to do
especially because you have like other
people like
um
Anna Kendrick who's able to have her
actual she gets to have the career and
then on an open
open ending for Haley Steinfeld as like
she's going to continue to write but we
don't know what will become of her
career and I thought that was very full
circle because the beginning I remember
one of the issues we had with the second
movie was that we felt like uh Becca was
kind of pushed to the side and she
originally started as like the main
focus of the first movie so I felt like
with this one what I liked about it was
that it brought back Becca being kind of
the main focus at the end yes and I also
really loved her and Fat Amy teaming up
together at the end because they were
always kind of like the stronger Duo I
would say so
and also her just randomly hating on
hailee Steinfeld the whole movie was
like such a weird but awesome like
running joke at the end like oh my God
shut up
yes we're Fat Amy didn't become funny to
me until she threatened her dad on the
phone with the call that was amazing
that when she started that and then like
everything she was doing after that was
like really funny that would be the
Oscar clip you know what I mean yeah
but yeah this one definitely like the
the last one becomes more heightened
um a little bit more zany and wacky a
little more cartoony and this one I felt
like they were just fully embraced uh
the hijinks of it without sacrificing
the heart like it's not it's not perfect
by any stretch you know despite that
fact that it's in the title it's by no
means perfect uh
like they got a lot of
repeat beats in the previous one I was
gonna say I can see how like some people
probably just didn't like it because
you're right there was some repetitive
things about this movie and also the
tone was just so different from the
other two which I didn't mind it because
I think it was still an enjoyable movie
to watch but like I can see how people
probably just was expecting the tone to
be the same and expecting those big
raunchy jokes and just weird which they
still had like sprinkles of it in but
like overall this was still a more I
would say cheesy movie in comparison
oh totally well it seemed like they had
a Pitch Perfect 3 script for another
competition and then somewhere down the
line someone said America this is too
real America
Happy Father's Day they said this is too
repetitive it's just the same plot again
of them competing against this
you know band like it was just
the same thing again
what if we throw in this thing with fat
Amy and let's just make some wacky
I was just thinking you really mix it up
when you set up the pitch meeting where
they're just like what if yeah but what
if we take this other screenplay I have
it's not fighting just smash them
together give this to Fat Amy about a
woman who ran away from her dad and
she's coming back in her life it really
seems like they suddenly had this like
crazy I was so fascinated to know how
this came to be because I could totally
see people not liking this movie for the
exact thing that I really ended up
surprisingly enjoying which was that
whole last like 20 minutes of this film
which I could totally see people
completely checking out and going too
much too cartoony and of course I would
never slight someone for feeling that
way I would be like I would never be
like you just don't get it I totally
understand if you don't like it uh but
for me it happened it was so weird here
but because of how confident they were
in doing it it worked for me it's the
action that did it for great guys like
had there been no action and he really
it sucked but but it was it was the
action that's what gets you Greg yeah so
yeah you just need action
uh I was also gonna say that okay so
like the first one was so raunchy kind
of reminded me of like a female I won't
I won't say super bad because I'll get
hate for that but you know what I mean
like kind of like a raunchy like female
movie which isn't
um done a lot I guess Mean Girls is kind
of that and so with this one it kind of
reminded me of like a Disney Channel
movie like what's this new cuss words in
there so that was different and I kind
of I had the idea my idea listen guys I
should work in Hollywood because my idea
was that they would like I thought I
called it in the other movie that they'd
go on tour but I thought it'd be more
like a they'd be touring kind of like
rock and roll style like going to City
to city and then
um they're being like crazy like
hangover plots going on which that's
kind of what I was expecting given you
know the tone of the others but then um
I halfway through I was like this is too
cheesy for me in like Disney Channel but
then it redeemed itself for me with with
the action uh parodies at the end and
then the that one conversation they all
had together kind of like tied it all
together for me so that's how I feel
about it I I hear what you mean like
there there's a there's a quality to it
that doesn't quite feel
it kind of feels like and I know this is
not the case this was released in the
theaters a couple years after Pitch
Perfect Two like a TV movie is that what
you're gonna say it kind of feels like
when Disney plus goes we're gonna do a
sequel finally to something and they
bring back the cast and everything and
then it's like kind of weird like yeah
this is sort of that yeah it has that it
has that touch I wonder what the Gap was
between the second movie and this movie
because that you're right it does kind
of feel like that like
2017 was this one
and Pitch Perfect Two
released hopefully autocorrect because I
can't see it was 2015. so literally two
years apart it just has that Vibe it
does
um that of like something soft but I
like reunion pandering I like the
riff-off scene here more than the second
I mean the first one's the best I agree
hands out hands down first one is the
best
uh the second one
like I don't think I don't remember it
I remember it before the setting of it
but
I remember because it was distracting
and how it it didn't sound real and not
like this one doesn't and what I mean by
that is like you can tell they're like
in a recording booth doing it this time
versus the first one felt like they were
really on the street doing it yeah and
uh this one I love that they embraced
the
how it turned into like a community
aspect and all the instruments and the
mixing and stuff and the mixing of the
different genres was cool you got
country you have rock you had rap or r b
and then Pop I actually thought that was
really cool yeah they did that very well
the only critique I have like filmmaker
critique about it is they were in this
big hangar
and there was no like Reverb there was
no Echo and that would have just been
such a cool I guess audio uh effect to
have for that sequence would have been
cool I mean yeah they they started
sacrificing that I think in the in the
second movies is that where people would
download these tracks like that
yeah it's realistic touches
um yeah I mean some of the com there's a
lot of like flat jokes in here there's a
lot of Comedy that is like there it
becomes it becomes so sick commie you
know where they're like what is the
funny thing about that person from last
movie okay let's just do that joke a
bunch uh yeah it wasn't as shy time like
I feel like the jokes in the first movie
The reason why it was so funny to us is
a lot of it was like shocking like you
weren't expecting it and in this movie I
felt like they were all kind of like
predictable jokes not all of them but
but a lot of them it turned it turned
them into sitcom characters a lot of
them don't feel like a real character
but when it got to the finale all that
started making sense to me for the kind
of Comedy this was where it it went to
like an like an Anchorman level kind of
Comedy or like a Will Ferrell type of
Comedy uh is is is yeah this kind of
like becomes a little more sketch
comedy-ish yes this one I would agree
with that yeah and then the yeah because
there's a lot of like they they keep the
girls obsessed with guys I like that
Anna Kendrick didn't end up with that
one dude um yeah he eliminated the
romance of that because that would have
been annoying repeat beat
um yeah no it's it's not
I thought he was gonna be evil too
so did I he comes across like he is just
looking so yeah this movie has a
terrible critic score and terrible
audience score oh my God it's nowhere
near fresh as an audience score 43
percent
and uh critics scores 28 all right so
you know I will gladly embrace the fact
that I really you know what I like
surprise on the second one I liked it
better than the second one yeah
I was just about to say I like it more
than the second one I I had more I had
and maybe because
it might have something to do with the
fact that we love the first one and then
the second one was like oh okay it was
as good as the first one and and then
this one people are like it's not good
so we go later I'm like I don't know
I would re-watch this one I don't I
wouldn't re-watch the second one to be
honest there was nothing about it that I
was like oh yeah
I surprisingly don't remember that much
about the second one me either me either
that's how I know the movie like at the
times I watch a movie I'm like oh it's
decent but like if if I know it's like
bad to me like it's usually because I
won't remember anything about it
well I love what I what did I like I
loved when they did embrace the the
heightened qualities of the second one a
lot like when they went when um when Fat
Amy's like rowing to come back no that
scene sticks out to me because we were
dying during that scene yeah
um but I remember that movie just being
feeling so long I think that's I think
that's why it's a long movie it was a
very long this one was more digestible
being a typical hour and a half
yeah so because they they set you up for
we're we're gonna pretty much do a lot
of the same tropes we've established in
the last two like with Ruby Rose and her
band like the competitive one they just
totally dropped that shot I know yeah I
forgot about them until until the end
when they're in the audience I was like
oh wait yeah they were supposed they
replaced all that run time with this
weird Fat Amy storyline and uh I could
have done without that scene between
them you know what I'm talking about
when they like meet up and she's like so
excited and then he's like I don't know
if I'm gonna like I was like that that
scene didn't add anything really except
the information are you talking about
exactly
it's the one where they were like
walking through a market and he was like
trying to convince her to like go with
him oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah I get what you're saying
um I mean I didn't mind it I thought it
was weird but it was weird why didn't
you like it
I just felt like it was it didn't fit
with the rest of the movie
like there was nothing funny about it it
was like very expositional but then that
could have been like
cut out and I think it still would have
been
cool
well you see they had that you said
expositional they have that joke and so
that's what I mean that's the kind of
Comedy that this one is it's I do like
it it calls itself aware yeah it's so
self-aware and and it's way more it's
way more self-aware than the other ones
yes um bio by a large margin and so I I
think that I appreciate that yeah so
that's what I mean by how it all I keep
saying it that's why I mean when my time
I got to that finale on the phone like
okay this whole movie subtly makes sense
to me and things really do make or break
a movie they really do like
um
also can I just point out I wore a
Twilight shirt specifically because Anna
Kendrick was in Twilight and also her
name's Bella and this is about the
Bellas so that was smart irony
you're a clever clever woman
well guys what do you think of Sally's
shirt where would you rank Pitch Perfect
three leave in the comments what you
would pitch for Pitch Perfect for
ooh
I want it to be like a Logan
like it's a super dower Oh I thought you
meant Logan Lerman I got really excited
no no one thinks of Logan Lerman
I do no one thinks of Wolverine and uh
follow Sally on YouTube where she's
youtubing it and hey thank you all for
being here on this journey
uh I love when we can complete a
franchise and uh I'm happy that this one
ended on a way that I personally thought
was a high note
so
yes
the kind of Comedy you get here real
reasons
alrighty guys Sally say bye to the
audience peace out
foreign